bonjour bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de ski mag
que vous soyez sportif plutôt farniente
nature ou culture que faire cet été à
saint quentin en yvelines
l'ide de loisirs regorge d'activités en
plein air mais aussi d'événements
côté culture la commanderie le théâtre
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines le musée de
la ville ou encore les médiathèque
propose des expositions des spectacles
des séances de cinéma en plein air ou
encore des visites en tous genres ont
fait le tour des programmes c'est parti
[Musique]
l'été enfin pour se ressourcer après une
nouvelle année sous le signe de la crise
sanitaire respirer au grand air profiter
de la nature pour se retrouver en
famille ou entre amis pour le farniente
ou l'action direction l'île de loisirs
ici à lille de loisirs nous avons un
espace de 600 hectares
[Musique]
bédié donc à la nature et à toutes les
activités qui s'y rapportent
on peut venir pique on peut venir
faire de la voile on peut venir faire de
l'accrobranche on peut venir se promener
faire du poney classée natura 2000 l'île
de loisirs est la plus grande ville de
france est la seule à posséder une
réserve naturelle nationale 120 hectares
sont recouverts par des plans d'eau la
faune ornithologique y est abondante et
côtoie lapin renard et sangliers côté
activités elles sont nombreuses et
variées golf pour tous centre équestre
pour débutants et au niveau ferme
pédagogique avec atelier centre de voile
avec initiation au catamaran paddle
planche à voile canoë kayak ou encore
accro branche sur le parcours
acrobatique en hauteur par exemple la
grande nouveauté cette année
[Musique]
m
on a ajouté un parcours donc des travaux
qui ont été importants notamment cet
hiver et jusqu'au début du printemps
puisque on a construit un nouveau
parcours bleu donc on s'est aperçu qu'il
y avait une grosse fréquentation sur
parcours bleu et vert donc on a créé un
parcours qui soit à peu près de ces
difficultés là de façon à fluidifier à
donner plus de place pour les personnes
qui naturellement s'orienter plus sur le
type de difficultés à la demande de la
clientèle le parcours noir le plus
difficile a également été doublé autre
nouveauté la visite de l'île en
trottinette électrique grâce à la
start-up trip une trotte une balade
accessible tout au long de la nuit donc
un accueil à partir de trottinettes
électriques tout et rend donc
complètement adapté en fait à aller de
loisirs et qui permettent en particulier
à des groupes de se balader de découvrir
le milieu
autre nouveauté encore au restaurant des
alizés cette année deux nocturnes les
vendredis et samedis soirs avec
animation musicale
le tout face au lac et au coucher de
soleil
l'île de loisirs c'est aussi des
événements tout l'été à commencer par
les tréteaux de france
j'ai très tôt trans qui reviennent pour
la quatrième année consécutive sur les
loisirs qu'on est très heureux
d'accueillir
[Musique]
c'est devenu vraiment un rendez vous
pour les franciliens et pour les saint
quentinois plus précisément qui nous
demande maintenant tous les ans quand
les tréteaux vont-ils revenir et qui
vont proposer tout un tas de spectacles
d'ateliers de spectacles aussi en
interaction avec le public
et puis d'autres plus classiques sous
chapiteau pendant pendant dix jours
autre rendez vous à ne pas manquer le
vilain geste sportif et on a tout un tas
d'activités a proposé d'activités
culturelles et c'est aussi un peu la
nouveauté avec la retransmission des
épreuves des jo sur le temps du midi des
ateliers radio d'une initiation aux
gestes qui sauvent une exposition sur
les jeux olympiques et la présentation
justement des sites olympiques de 2024
dans les activités de nouvelles offres
proposées du breakdance cette année et
du basket donc activités qui seront
olympique ainsi que de l escalade et et
on a deux journées qu'on va
particulièrement ouvrir aux familles ce
sont le 27 juillet et le 2 août ou du
coup les bains des familles pourront
s'initier à toutes les activités qu'on
propose le hockey le rugby la boxe
l'escaladent le baseball etc
[Musique]
ça c'était pour les plus sportifs pour
les passionnés de culture de musique de
théâtre les multiples culturel saint
quentinois ont concocté une
programmation très variée notamment en
plein air pour les plus petits comme
pour les grands
[Musique]
si on quitte la base de loisirs où on
fait bouger son corps on peut aussi
faire bouger son esprit
grâce au réseau de médiathèques qui va
rester très actif le réseau des
médiathèques a toujours été actif un
même pendant les périodes de confinement
cet été c'est un peu là la renaissance
de la saison culturelle puisque après
deux années très difficiles
on a voulu marquer un petit peu cette
saison estivale avec de très nombreuses
activités qui vont mettre en action
toutes les structures culturelles du
territoire
donc aujourd'hui c'est un petit peu le
retour à une vie culturelle en
présentiel donc avec partir en livre la
grande opération du réseau des
médiathèques qui va se poursuivre
pendant tout le mois de juillet compte
rencontre avec les auteurs ateliers pour
tous publics
le réseau des médiathèques propose la
mise en commun des collections des
services et des actions culturelles au
profit de tous les habitants de saint
quentinois les médiathèques du canal à
montigny le bretonneux et jacques
prévert hop les sous bois invite en
terrasse avec transats et parasols pour
suivre les comptes et les animations
le bibliobus sillonnera également les
communes cet été
[Musique]
autre lieu autre distraction à la
commanderie lieu de l'innovation
culturelle de saint quentin en yvelines
cet été tous les arts s'y côtoient à
travers des ateliers spectacles
résidence exposition villages
thématiques et des temps forts avec des
concerts et cinéma de plein air
ainsi que des stages culturels pour le
jeune public
[Musique]
le musée de la ville n'est pas en reste
bien sûr cet été il nous offre
l'exposition la ville a habité qui
permettra aux habitants de re découvrir
ou de redécouvrir un petit peu toute
l'agglomération et son histoire
et puis bien évidemment les enfants ne
sont pas oubliés puisqu'ils y aura des
ateliers où ils ont la possibilité de
s'intéresser justement tout ce qui a
fait 7
cette agglomération musées de la ville
possède une collection de six mille
objets liés à l'histoire des territoires
et à l'évolution des modes de vie
un carnet de voyage invite à découvrir
le territoire à travers des balades en
autonomie aux quatre coins de saint
quentin en yvelines pour la fin de l'été
le théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
ouvre ses pentes
alors le théâtre cet été à saint quentin
en yvelines il nous va nous proposer la
programmation dite escapade avec neuf
représentations dans les murs et hors
les murs qui associeront les différentes
activités scéniques le théâtre vivant
bien sûr mais aussi la danse et la
musique et avec notamment un spectacle
participatif
à travers cette programmation la scène
nationale propose pour la rentrée des
spectacles de danse musique baroque
classique contemporaine
pour des retrouvailles en plein air
[Musique]
visiter la france sans quitter
l'agglomération c'est possible rendez
vous sur le site de france miniature à
elancourt
le parc qui fête ses 30 ans cette année
propose un tour de france de 117
monument miniaturisés sur cinq hectares
pour la vallée de chevreuse direction la
gare de la verrière 50 ans on peut se
balader à pied on l'a vu mais aussi on
peut prendre le balade au bus à la gare
de la verrière qui vous conduira pour
visiter ou revisiter les sites
remarquables de la vallée de chevreuse
le site auto royal bien sûr le château
de la madeleine et beaucoup d'autres à
pied en bus ou à vélo
saint quentin en yvelines possède plus
de 400 km de pistes cyclables pour une
balade sur deux roues en toute quiétude
à pied en bus à vélo ou à la nage la
piscine salvador allende aux
clayes-sous-bois offre un bassin
découvrable de 25 mètres et un solarium
pour les journées les plus chaudes de
l'été des stages de natation sont
proposés pour les 6 12 ans
[Musique]
pour une pause fraîcheur rendez-vous
également dans les salles obscures à
willencourt trappe aux clayes-sous-bois
à montigny le bretonneux ou encore à
plaisir avec un complexe de neuf salles
et 1279 place faites votre choix
si mike c'est fini n'oubliez pas que
vous pouvez accéder au vélodrome tout
l'été pour vous faire vacciner très bel
été à toutes et à tous ciao
[Musique]